Democratic congressman Adam Schiff of
California is the ranking member on the
House Intelligence Committee he is with
us from Capitol Hill congressman good
morning good morning not only does the
former FBI director have a memo about
this conversation which he accuses the
president saying I hope you can let it
go but he has memos of every single
phone conversation and meeting he had
with President Trump will you be allowed
to see those memos I'm confident that
Congress is going to get those memoranda
and we already had requests from one of
the Republican chairs to do that I'm
also confident that director Comey will
come back and testify before Congress as
indeed he should these are very
explosive charges that are contained in
that airtimes report we need to get to
bond at the bottom of them and of course
you laid out a lot of the chronology but
just to put this in context you have
Michael Flynn one of the most prominent
surrogates for the president during the
campaign accepting money from Russian
entities not reporting that then
apparently having conversations that he
lied about with the vice president the
vice president misleading the country
the president not taking action on that
for weeks until it became public than
firing Flynn then the president
attacking the press over it the
president asking the FBI director
whether that the President himself was
potentially a target of the
investigation while the director
purportedly was worried about keeping
his job and then you have this final
allegation that the president tried to
make the Flint investigation go away
that is a very serious pattern of events
yeah and all this of course yes
congressman when you lay it out it
certainly sounds very damaging I'm
curious about what you're hearing from
your Republican colleagues we've reached
out to close to 20 of your colleagues
all of them refused to come on this
program today it was like crickets over
there in Washington what are you hearing
from them what are they saying what
should they be saying or doing in your
opinion well you know I think there's a
lot of deep concern on both sides of the
aisle over the conduct of the
administration not only in terms of the
propriety or propriety of what the
president is doing but just the fact
that this administration is in constant
turmoil
and we haven't had an external crisis
yet these are all crisis of the
president's own making what's going to
happen when we need to confront a
serious external challenge so I think
members on both sides of the aisle
deeply concerned about just how
dysfunctional this administration and
where this will lead even if we accepted
what's happened up to this point it's
troubling enough but none of us know
what is yet to come I think we're seeing
an increasing number of Republicans
willing to speak out willing to even
more important than speaking out take
action like support and independent
council support an independent
commission or request testimony and
documents so you think there's a
developing consensus for an independent
commission or an independent
investigation beyond the housing and
Senate intelligence committees well it's
certainly the right policy decision it's
the right decision for the country as
we've seen consent work that it's
necessary is the question I wouldn't say
I wouldn't say consensus there is
increasing support and you have a number
Republicans now who are coming out in
favor of either an independent council
or Commission I don't think we're at the
critical mass yet but we may be getting
there and I know the republicans are
conferencing this morning and we'll see
what comes out of that put it there well
we may you know we may be there just by
dint of the events that have taken place
already I have to imagine when we get
these memoranda if they betray
conversations the president had that
show a lack of ethics by the president
or potential illegalities
then you're going to have more than
enough to compel the GOP conference and
and most importantly the speaker and
Mitch McConnell to do the right thing
for the country right now he said he
said who do you believe he said I think
the country is going to believe director
Comey he's far more credible
particularly when it comes to anything
to do with the Russia investigation if
you look just at the events of this week
you had the president's surrogates out
there saying one thing you had the vice
president out there how does the
position of saying something that
possibly wasn't true Congress I was
gonna ask you about some news this
morning the Russian President Vladimir
Putin just offered to provide a
transcript president Trump's Oval Office
conversation with the Russian Foreign
Minister that's the meeting where Trump
discussed classified information would
you accept that offer from the Russians
well I have to say I find that quite
amusing in two regards first probably
the last person the president needs to
vouch for him right now is Vladimir
Putin but even beyond that the Russians
have denied that they were even involved
in hacking our democratic institutions
who is going to give them any weight
whatsoever so if they want to send
something you know hats off send it our
way but whether it would be given any
credibility I can tell you its
credibility would be less than zero
thank you congressman Schiff good to see
you thank you for joining us thank you